this is how it usually plays out your on
date number four with that cute guy
Craig from bumble and it seems to be
going really well then he casually slips
in a comment about your ovarian future
it's a great salad so you at that age
where you're thinking about freezing
your eggs that look on my face is a mix
of horror and realization and both are
linked to Craig's poop idea that I and I
alone carry the burden of healthy
fertility with an aging body and that
idea is rooted in the ever dreaded
biological clock the biological clock is
a phrase that's had a few different
meanings over time but is typically used
to refer to how female fertility
specifically declines with age hey guys
I'm Sonny and this Sunday we're gonna
talk about the history of the biological
clock and how capitalism has a lot to
say about my eggs and if you like this
video and other stuff that we do here at
because facts and don't forget to hit
that subscribe button and that belt to
get notifications do right now right
before we get into it
the actual phrase biological clock
wasn't always used to refer to how long
women had until their reproduction
ability plummeted they used to refer to
the human body circadian rhythm how you
sleep when you sleep when you wake up
that sort of stuff
Maura Wagle author and scholar of gender
and sexuality notes that that phrase it
came to mean something very different in
the 1970s the phrase biological clock in
the sense that we use it now enters the
popular imagination the popular lexicon
at a very particular moment in American
history it's the way at 1970s it's sort
of after this period of real flourishing
in advance for the feminist movement and
the women's movement in fact Wagle even
pinpoints the day it enters a popular
imagination March 16th in 1978 that's
when Washington Post columnist Richard
Cohen wrote a piece in the Metro section
called the clock is ticking for career
women about how even though career women
seem to have it all they are still not
fulfilled until they can have a baby to
a certain extent the biological clock is
naming that real phenomenon but I think
that the purchase that it gains in
culture generally cannot be separated
from changes like the entrance of large
numbers of middle-class college-educated
women into parts of the workforce that
they had historically been excluded from
women using contraception and abortion
to delay motherhood so it's no big
coincidence that the Year Cohen used a
term biological clock to refer to
women's declining fertility is also the
same year that we see the first
so-called test tube baby conceived
through in vitro fertilization so at the
same time that you have this
increasingly widespread discourse in the
American media about declining female
fertility and anxiety about the
biological clock there major advances
taking place in assisted reproductive
technology and in in vitro fertilization
and we'll talk about the fertility
industry and IVF in just a moment so
hold on now the idea of a woman's
fertility competing with her ambitions
in life continued to develop in the
media and pop culture throughout the 80s
you're 31 years old and the clock is
ticking now the clock doesn't really
start to take until you're 36 the 90s
the daughter of my sister
getting married my biological clock is
tickin like this and the way this case
is going
I ain't never gettin married and mm a
lot of women today for whatever reason
are starting their families a little
later so they want to know how much time
do I have and there's something very
hiding something very scolding I would
say about this discourse saying that
women who thought that they could have
it all who thought that they could have
education and have careers and still
have families are taking a serious risk
of ending up alone now dr. Lynn Westfall
of Stanford Medical School does note
that the focus on women's reproductive
aging is fair when we compare women's
fertility to men's the focus on
fertility has to focus primarily on
women because all women will eventually
become infertile if they live long
enough there's no way to prevent
menopause eventually all the eggs will
be depleted from the ovaries and that
usually happens around age 50 and at
that point there are no more eggs and a
woman cannot get pregnant naturally
while there's a chance that men can
reproduce in their 80s or 90s that
doesn't necessarily mean that their
sperm is in great health people are not
as efficient as at reproducing as a lot
of people think we know that a normal
fertile couple in their 20s has probably
about a 20 maybe 25% chance of getting
pregnant each month on their own they
aged 40 that falls to about a 5% we have
focused a lot on the health of the woman
but the health of the male is very
important to research from 2012 found
that male reproductive aging mattered
for the mental health of the child
specifically increasing the risk for
schizophrenia and autism relatedly but
not connected to aging research from
2017 found that between 1973 and 2011
sperm count in men from 50 different
Western countries had fallen between 50
and 60% studies have shown a decline in
sperm counts around the world the
decline in sperm count is not a problem
with our technology so we can overcome
that the aging of the egg and decreasing
quality of the egg we don't have a way
to correct at this point and while dr.
Westphal makes the point that the focus
on women's reproductive aging is
warranted because we do have an end date
aka menopause it's worth exploring when
and why that became such a focus in the
media the emergence of the biological
clock as something that specifically
refers to women's fertility came about
in the context of the women's rights
movements making significant gains in
the 60s and 70s we're talking about the
Equal Pay Act of 1963 roe v wade in 1973
and the Pregnancy Discrimination Act of
1978 American women especially white
American women not only had the
opportunity to control their
reproductive future but also enter the
workforce in greater numbers than ever
before and her seminal book backlash
Pulitzer prize-winning journalist Susan
Faludi describes the era of Ronald
Reagan's presidency as an undeclared war
against American women one of the
problems threatening the American family
and therefore the fabric of society was
that women were having children at later
ages according to the Centers for
Disease Control between 1970 and 2000
the median age of a first-time mother
rose from about 22 to almost 25 and the
national birth rate had been falling for
almost two decades in 1957 the average
American woman has three and a half
children by 1976 that number had fallen
to one and a half while women in the
United States in particular were and are
still choosing to have children later in
life the conversation has focused on
that being the result of this
competition between motherhood and
ambition and that's very much still the
case take for example Ann Marie
slaughters viral Atlantic piece why
women still can't have it all and Sheryl
Sandberg's book lean in but recent
research indicates that women who are
delaying motherhood might not be doing
it because of their careers medical
anthropologist Marcia in Hoorn found in
a recent study women who are freezing
their eggs aren't doing it out of career
ambitions but because they can't find
the right partner and if they are
delaying motherhood because of their
career
that's because corporate America by
design it was meant for men not for
women as wigle points out the idea again
that we see again and again throughout
the history of this biological clock
conversation is that if women are having
trouble Balan
saying work and life or fitting the
patterns of their lives their personal
and biological lives to a corporate
system that was not designed to
accommodate women the solution is not
paid leave more generous child care
benefits the solution is an expensive
technological fix that is out beyond
reach for many for many people's that
technological fix has given birth no pun
intended to an entire industry that
ultimately works off the fears of
college-educated working women ok pun
intended I mentioned earlier the first
IVF baby was born around the same time
that the biological clock metaphor
entered the American imagination and it
was a huge deal by the way women who
previously were unable to bear children
because of blocked fallopian tubes
fertility issues or even survivors of
ovarian cancer were able to finally have
kids today thanks to other technological
advances like egg freezing fertility is
a huge industry estimate to hit four
billion dollars in 2018 but while the
fertility industry is growing it's also
been criticized for over selling while
IVF and egg freezing are presented as
part of the solution for career-oriented
women who want it all there are success
rates do decline with age around 40% of
IVF cycles result in babies for women
age 32 and younger not even ten years
later for women aged 40 that success
rate is cut in half to less than 20% and
even then these treatments are
financially out of reach for many if not
most women
freezing your eggs can cost around
$11,000 for a single round of retrieval
plus there's a storage fees to keep your
eggs safely frozen anywhere from $250 to
$1,500 annually then there's IVF which
can cost around $12,000 per round plus
three to five thousand dollars for the
necessary hormonal drugs 70% of women
who get fertility treatments actually go
into debt and while sperm freezing and
storing which by the way is different
from sperm banks is becoming a thing
among men due to concerns about sperm
count and aging it's nowhere near the
same industry as it is for women so is
this really a solution and is there
really a competition between ambition
and motherhood and is the biological
clock real son I could you just say yes
or no well it's complicated because
women do have an expiration date on
their fertility
but as Wagle points out we can't divorce
the way we talk about the biological
clock in this country from the history
of women's labor this idea that
professional women educated women are
going about their lives wrong that
they're organizing their lives the wrong
way prioritizing the wrong things not
setting enough stock in traditional ways
of doing things
is yet another expression of this
cultural anxiety that we see throughout
the history of dating about people of
all genders but women in particular
getting more control over their personal
professional intimate reproductive lives
so have any of you guys actually had any
kind of sperm freezing or egg freezing
ads targeted towards you on social media
or anywhere let us know in the comments
and don't forget to Like share and
subscribe and what is those there any
other health stories you want us to
cover